let's get to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we are going to start today with our
caller from the three three six area
code lots of people holding don't hang
up we're gonna try to get to a bunch of
calls today three three six go ahead
jump right into your question if you'd
like so I'm wondering why it seems okay
for Christians to be criticized but not
other religions per se give me an
example of that well it seems like it's
everything on the news lately is
right-wing conservative men are racist
anti-gay etc the list goes on so you
said that on the news right-wing
conservative men are those things but
your first thing was about criticizing
Christians but then you didn't mention
Christians in terms are you saying that
right-wing conservatives are by
definition Christians no I'm not
necessarily saying I'm I'm using myself
as an example so what's an example of
how the how Christians are being
criticized it seems like Christians are
generalized I like it watching your show
I feel like you are relatively unbiased
you try to stay neutral even if you
don't necessarily agree with other
perspective okay but what's an example
so can you so give me in give me an
example of where Christians are
generalized about the Christians are
generalized as taking every word of the
Bible literally being irrational for
taking everywhere to the Bible literally
where the where did you see that general
it's an example of where you saw that
generalization you said in the news all
the time now like what would be an
example of that well with that the
recent stuff with the border stuff it's
it's how can you be a Christian at your
pro-trump with what he's doing at the
border separating children from their
parents okay and you think that so who's
being generalized about I feel like
Christians in general yeah I guess I'm
just another understanding I mean it
seems to me the
there were some on the right who used
the Bible to justify the policy and then
the reaction to that was it doesn't seem
very Christian to separate kids from
their parents but that's not a
generalization about Christians that's
directly saying using the Bible to
justify the policy is wrong that seems
to be not what you're saying it is no I
guess I didn't have an appropriate
example on hand no is there a different
example maybe that you have
well I'm very into the evolution
creationism stuff you you have a lot on
that on your channel and so what what
would so what's the generalization there
it's it seems like it's it's pretty
commonly accepted if you're a Christian
and you believe the Bible you can't be
as rational as someone who doesn't
believe the Bible on it is atheist and
believes everything about evolution
that's ever been said and who's making
that argument atheist on every YouTube
channel Hans Internet I mean is there a
difference between focusing specifically
on the idea of creationism versus
evolution that might not be the same
thing as making these broad
generalizations you're alleging what do
you mean in other words just because
someone makes the case that the
empirical and scientific explanation for
how humans got to be the way they are is
the one that is presented by science
rather than the Christian Bible that's
not an ad hominem or a generalization
about Christians is it that's just a
very specific truth claim about two
competing theories correct I I just feel
like it's you feel like I got you I
think I understand you feel as though
this is taking place is that the really
the key thing yeah I feel like there's
Christians that have a voice on the news
and on the Internet yeah a bit say these
things that don't necessarily represent
the rest of us me that's fair that's a
fair criticism yeah some sometimes the
Chris
that are brought on to debate in media
have views that not every Christian
necessarily adheres to and I think that
that would apply to any religious group
or even even non-religious groups listen
I appreciate the call I'm glad we were
able to sort of suss out what you do
mean and and what you don't mean I
appreciate you taking the time